so
[Music]
hi guys welcome back to my youtube
channel mason troll tips and tricks
if this is your first time here my name
is phil and i teach people how to set up
and run amazak
cnc lathe while programming it with
mesatrol
this next video idea was from a viewer
suggestion
dan was stuck on how to program this
lathe part and i was able to help him
out
he suggested i make a video explaining
the steps i took
in creating his program in this video
i'm going to show you guys how to
program a roller
using four different programming methods
three of the methods involving having
some cad geometry data points
and the last method is strictly
programming the part at the machine
with no help from a cad program which
incidentally is the fastest
and simplest method of all four examples
all right let's get started
all right guys here's our next program
that we're going to be
creating this is a roller
and it's a diameter with a
taper a radius
and another taper and it has two small
radiuses in the corners here
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you the
most common method that people would use
to program this
which is describing every single
uh feature on the part
so let's get started so the first thing
we're going to do is push the left
button
go to program program file
select a work number that's not listed
up here i'm going to select work number
50.
so go back to program work number 50.
and if it's a new program push the
program button
mazotrol workpiece material is aluminum
max outside diameter workpiece is
3.25 inches inside is zero
workpiece length is five inches long
the max spindle limit this is the g50
for the entire program
i don't want to run the chuck past 2000
rpm
finish allowance on x is 10 000 on the
diameter
and finish allowance on z is 5 000
stock removal of work face this part is
already cleaned up
and i'm just going to set z off of the
finished surface so i'm going to leave
this at zero
first thing we're going to do is turn on
the coolant m code
cooling on down arrow now let's start
programming this feature
so we're going to do the bar stock
on the outside diameter cutting point on
x
is 3.25 cutting point on z
is zero and then we're going to do
uh let's just do auto for the speeds and
feeds
but i'm going to change it to eight
thousandth feed rate
and fifty thousand step to cut
i'm planning on running this with no
coolant
in just one tool so i'm going to run it
with
a 35 degree diamond which is tool two
offset one tool two offset one
all right here's our part i have all of
the
intersect points drawn up in cad
and i'm going to do it aligned
radius line radius line radius and line
so linear starting corner is 30
thousandths
final point on x is three inches in
diameter
and the final point on z is going to be
nine
two six eight
so the next thing we're going to do is
put a convex radius here
continue so that puts the start point
here and now the final point is going to
be this intersection right here is 2.921
and 1.0617
and the radius for this is 250
down arrow and we're going to do a taper
continue now the taper ends at 2.237
and 1.5954
so now the next thing we're going to do
is do a concave radius
and we're going to give it this data
point over here
so concave push continue
2.237
2.4046
and the radius is 0.750
so now we're going to do a taper up this
direction
to this intersect point
continue
2.921
and 2.9383
so now what we need to do is do another
concave radius
to three inch diameter
so con excuse me convex radius
continue three inch
and 3.073
and the radius is 0.2 0.250
so now what we need to do is do a linear
[Music]
three inch diameter and then we're going
to go back four inches long
and then what we're going to do is do a
chamfer at 3.25
so linear again 30 thousandths
3.25 and then 4.032
on the length down arrow
shape in right button
figure check and
there's our part that we have drawn in
there
so this is the most difficult way to
draw this feature
is with every little single radius
and line you can do it but it's not
necessary on this machine
so now what we want to do
is i'm going to create the same thing
and then it's going to overlay it on top
of this
so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to put this radius here
as a tangent radius in the machine
so let's go bar out 3.25
auto
and what we're going to do
is draw a line over to here
so this is our print so the
intersect point between this horizontal
and this taper is a one inch
length
so linear 30 thousandths chamfer
three inch diameter we're going to go
back one inch
to this intersect point
so now what we're going to do is do a
taper and then put a radius in here
push radius 0.250
push continue and now we're going to put
this intersect position down here
[Music]
2.237
and 1.5954
so now we're going to program this
concave radius
so right here concave continue
2.237
and 2.4046
and then the radius is 0.75
and we're going to do a taper from here
to here
so the final point on x is three inches
and three inches back on z
and then we're going to do a horizontal
line here
three inch diameter four inches long so
linear
we're going to put a radius in here of
0.250
so that way it breaks this corner to a
radius
three inches four inches long
linear
so now right button figure check
and there's no change in the graphics
because it overwrote
right on top of the existing one
so the first example
used eight lines of code
the second example used only six lines
of code
to give us what we want so now i'll show
you the third method
so bar out
3.25 auto
so the first one is the horizontal line
with the chamfer
so linear thirty thousandths
three inches long and we're going to go
back one inch deep
now we're going to do a taper push the
radius button
0.250 and now
push continue and now on this taper
we're going to come down to this point
here
so this is the intersect point of this
angle
and this angle with this tangent radius
between them
and the bottom of that tangent radius is
a two inch diameter
but the intersect position
is actually lower at 1.7184
and it's two inches back
and down arrow so now what we're going
to do
is do a line from here to here
and then put this radius at the front of
this
line so go taper push
radius 0.750
push continue final point on x is 3
inches
final point on z is 3 inches
down arrow linear radius
250 and we're going to do this
horizontal line here
and now we're going to break the edge so
linear 0.030
3.25 4.032
down arrow shape in so now this one
is the least of our data points and we
only used
one cad point that we had to calculate
instead of all of these cad points that
were required
so right button figure check so it's
going to draw it
three times on top of each other
so now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to do it a fourth time
so now this is without any cat
information at all
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
erase all of this above it
because this is all information we put
in with a cad drawing
and i want to do it right off of the
print without any cad data points
so right button erase input
so we'll erase everything so now we're
going to do it without a cad
assistance all right now that i have it
erased
now i'm going to program this part as if
we don't have
any cad help at all
so here's our part
and we don't know the intersect points
of anything here
so let's go bar stock out
3.25 auto
8 000 speed rate 50 000 step to cut
linear thirty thousands chamfer
three inch diameter one inch back
and the surface roughness is six i'm
going to actually use this
program to run the part
so next thing i want to do is do a taper
a radius 0.250
push continue
and we're going to program a corner down
here
so we're going to estimate this angle at
a minus 35 degrees
the print doesn't actually specify the
angle i'm just eyeballing the print
and this is just to get me in the
ballpark i'm going to fine tune that
angle
as we go so
final point on x is question mark
final point on z is two inches
taper angle is -35
surface roughness is six calculate
now i'm going to do a taper with this
radius in
it as a tangent radius between this
taper and this tape
so push continue and push radius
0.750
we're going to go back up here to three
inch diameter
and three inches long
so now what we're going to do is do a
linear across to here
three inch diameter four inches back
radius of 0.250
so now let's take a look at our part
so here's our
part drawn up so what i would need to do
is i need to put a horizontal line with
extra geometry down here at a two inch
diameter
i'm going to adjust this corner this end
point
until it falls tangent to this two inch
line
the newer controls like the t plus
control
will calculate a radius with an angle
but this old t3 control will not do that
so this is how to do it on a t3 but this
next step is
uh not necessary on a t plus because
it'll calculate that
center position and that angle
by giving it the center of that radius
so let's show you how to do it on the t3
so bar ow
and i got to give it a tool so tool two
linear and i need a diameter
two inch diameter and i'm going to go
back four inches back
shape in
so now we have some construction
geometry
at two inches diameter and that's what
the print shows that
to be tangent to right at the
root of that radius so let's zoom in
on this area right here
so now we can see it's not tangent
so let's go ahead and correct the
geometry
we already know what this intersect
position is because we
did calculate the cad geometry already
on the previous example
but we're going to just put numbers in
here
until it gives us a tangent point
so this is not the exact way to do it
this is gets you real close so this will
get you within five thousands
so final point on x let's change that to
one point seven
and then 1.7 here right button
figure check
so now it's a lot closer we're going to
zoom it in a little bit more
so 0.1 is the highest magnification on
this older control
but we can still see a gap in
so let's change it by 10 000 at a time
1.710
scale input
and we can see the line is still below
it but it's getting closer
so let's go another ten thousandths one
point seven twenty
scale input
and now that looks like it's touching
that line exactly
however because we did calculate that
point
that intersect position is 1.7184
so i'm going to move it 5 000 above this
1.725
right button figure check
so this is only five thousands different
from the previous one
and we can clearly see a gap in there so
even though this is kind of a crude
method
to get the geometry it's still within
about five thousandths of
actual geometry so let's go back to the
program
and let's type in the actual intersect
position
1.7184
and we'll see what it looks like
so with the perfect part we can see
with the pixel on the screen one pixel
is below it
and the other ones are above it so
that's what this machine looks like
with perfect geometry
so let's zoom out so scale one
and now we do not need this
construction geometry so we're going to
erase it
so right button erase input
left button program check
scale input and then push
shape so there's our part
so now we're going to do check continue
and we're nibbling at 50 000 steps to
cut with
the 35 degree diameter
full path of rigs
[Music]
and there we go all right from this
point let's set the work shift
and let's run this part
[Music]
all right that looks pretty good program
file
z offset teach zero input
we got our work shift set
[Music]
so let's back off
so left button go to position
auto work number work piece number is
50 input and
we're 1 10 behind our zero um
sometimes it's a tenth sometimes it's
zero
so today was the temp let's go to the
tray screen
we can see our 35 degree diamond turning
tool touching the face of the work
piece so let's back it off
[Music]
and let's go ahead and run it
all right auto and we're going to leave
the coolant off
so let's go ahead and run it
so
hmm
and we're done
and there's our finished workpiece if
you guys like what you see
go ahead and push that subscribe button
and click the bell so you won't miss any
future videos we have coming out
if you guys found this video to be
helpful please give it a thumbs up
that helps my channel and helps youtube
share this video with more people
also if you guys have suggestions for
future videos please let me know
down in the comments thanks again for
watching